two trillion dollars in taxes but six
trillion in spending and 22 trillion in
borrowing what can go wrong and i was
like
i should buy stuff
yeah and i'm like what do you buy
stock
no i mean crypto and land gold and
crypto i guess yeah copper so i bought
guns yeah guns are always going to be
good investment i'm sorry but but but
not because i'm like the apocalypse is
nigh no i was actually thinking like if
i buy a car
cars go down exactly exactly i have some
cryptocurrency i have some gold and
silver like what's a good thing that's
functional important so what did i get i
bought mouthwash yes isopropyl alcohol
and guns
because guns are
are like they're machines they're simple
machines they work well and my worst
case scenario is like i just you know
end up selling them back to stores or
something or just have them and i think
you know it'll be fun to go to the range
and we can film videos and we can talk
about i look at it like the worst case
scenario for me is i have these guns we
can just do vlogs where we're like
explaining and we get someone out to
talk to us about the different kinds and
everything and i'm just like
i don't want to sit here
and just have dollars that is appearing
it was i'll tell you it was really
freaky because we built this the park
does the skate park for the for the
vlogs and the shows and we're like
trying to make this big fun space some
people said it's like fantasy factory or
whatever and i was like i want to make a
big cultural thing and i'm looking at
the prices to do what we already did we
wouldn't be able to do it right now geez
yeah and so i'm like so so so by sheer
nature of just
having money sit around i've lost the
ability to grow the business
so it's like i'm trying to figure out
what i'm like higher higher bunch of
people asap just hire everybody like
you're hired i don't know yeah i'd
rather have the person here doing
backflips and cartwheels in the front
lawn then just having money disappeared
yeah then the problem is as the uh as
the dollar inflates it becomes more and
more expensive to keep all the people
you just hired that's a good point i
mean
well if
like what like the food will get too
expensive yeah like their cost of living
is going to increase a lot yeah i know
then i'll just build you know like uh
the tim compound fun fact no no we'll
get we'll we'll get maybe like a couple
hundred square feet but we'll make you
know stand-up sleeping rooms so we can
fit three hundred people called the
closet yeah
what we'll do is we'll get sleeping bags
that hang so you you you climb in and
zip up and just hang and you don't need
space that's smart it's time to wake up
they come in and hit it with us who
needs privacy yeah we'll just put them
all against the wall in fact we'll
double out we'll double them up just use
plastic bags there's a lot of cicadas
out eat the bugs the front of your
sleeping bag has another hook to hang
another person on the sleeping bag yeah
yeah have like a little kangaroo pouch
dude we're all gonna get real close huh
people should get out of cities man if
you can that's a good a good a good
really good idea yeah i think i'm going
to do that like i go outside you know
there's like there's like an egg like i
walk into the chicken thing it's like an
egg i just take it and i'm like i wash
it off and i eat it that's true in my
city too but i live in a very southern
city you know just exactly what's the
city so i'm just i don't want to dox
myself oh smart stuff so the cicadas are
getting crazy
they're like
at first they're on the trees and
they're they're they all scream have you
ever heard of
them
it's their wings i hear they're flapping
their wings so fast it sounds like
they're snowing no no no no no no
they're actually screaming i don't know
if they're actually screaming but there
was one flying above me and it wasn't
noisy and then when i went to swat it
went up and i was like wow yeah that
happened dude one of them landed on me
and then i was like get off me and i
like blew on it and i was like i was
like oh my god
it was terrible uh
i got i have this thing called the bug
assault yeah
pump action salt blaster for bugs and so
what happens is cicada when it like
flies at me i take its wing out and then
toss it to the chickens so i basically
been harvesting cicadas from the air to
give to the chickens chickens are going
us they're eating them all up when tim
said he bought a bunch of guns that's
what he was talking
about shots
nerf that's what i call an assault
weapon so the thing about the cicadas is
we had those in the area i grew up i
grew up right outside chicago and
we got that i think we're about two
years different from you guys with the
17-year cycle but the ground was like
black it was just covered in cicadas it
was worse than it was here they were
everywhere
i saw a photo from loudoun county and it
was a bush with every leaf was just
covered in cicadas like it was like a
bush but it was brown and i was like
would it be great to like throw a net
over that catch them all and throw them
into a chicken coop just eat them just
eat the bugs
don't don't why not what's wrong they
taste terrible i've heard yeah i
somebody told me that one of their
friends ate where i think uh somebody
here was telling me that their their
boyfriend ate one and that it tasted
disgusting no delicious
you should try it leave you you should
try it no it's really good do it on air
no now we're talking you've got to grind
it up and put it out you're talking
about like
and soak in it why don't you make cicada
bread
i don't want to i will
they were farmed fried and milled
the the cicadas are like dude they're
out of the ground in like the middle of
nowhere there's going to be like weird
parasites and they have that they have
that new that well i'll tell you this
they have some kind of like fungus
disease
that i think they're they're now they
have psilocybin or something like that
oh my gosh did you guys see that did you
hear something like that i did yeah what
is this whoa dude people going on yeah
so they're getting this fungus and it
makes them go crazy and they become even
more
um insane about having cicada babies and
they start shaking really really really
really really fast and they basically
like implode their butts fall off
have you confirmed that it's psilocybin
no ian's like i want to eat them now
i'm looking into it
no it's it is some form of
hallucinogenic fungus which is really
interesting so wait a minute next thing
we know like in the backyard
i didn't like it
[Laughter]
that'd be interesting are you guys
familiar with ergot yeah that's what
yeah lsd comes in yeah they they
synthesized it out of ergotamine lsd is
synthesized out of ergotamine which is
fungus that grows
yeah and like they say the salem
witchcraft trials they went insane
because they were getting ergot
poisoning and they didn't know so they
thought everybody was like uh and all
these things in the past have been
attributed to it like the dancing plague
have you ever heard of that yes in
europe all these people started dancing
and like it was during the plague and
they just came out of their houses and
for days they would dance until they
died yes go
fever could you imagine being like a
woman during the salem witch trials and
you're like churning butter and then all
of a sudden some guy walks up here and
he's tripping balls and he's like
witch so then they beat you to death
it's horrible what did i do
that's just making butter
do you guys think that's why the salem
witch trials have but i've heard that
they were like hallucinating yeah yeah
they were tripping they were eating like
contaminated rye basically bread it was
the ergot was growing on the rye yeah so
actually let's let's put in today's
terms imagine you're chilling in your
living room and you're like watching a
show and ian walks in tripping balls and
he's like
rich and then everyone runs in and
starts beating you with like clubs and
stuff
i mean really the people who are
never doing it
you have my word but i just keep cutting
it i'm um confirming this a fungus is
pushing cicada sex into hyperdrive yep
and leaving them dismembered so you guys
have read this yeah so i guess their um
private parts fall off because they get
moving too the fungus
is the name of the fungus you got to
research it for us this is kind of
really curious
in amphetamine
all right let me read we got from npr
they say after 17 years underground the
brood x periodical cicadas are slowly
emerging in 15 states yeah we know
they'll shed their skins and spend four
to six weeks mating before the female
lay eggs and then they all die
but some of them are getting wilder a
fungus called masospora which can
produce compounds of cathinone and
amphetamine infects a smallness so their
uppers do
infect a small number of them and makes
them lose control it takes over their
bodies causing them to lose their lower
abdomen and genitals and it pushes their
mating and hyperdrive but they don't
have junk how they can do it this is
stranger than fiction matt kassing an
associate professor of forest pathology
and mycology at west virginia university
tells npr's all things considered to
have something that's being manipulated
by a fungus to be hyper-sexual and have
prolonged stamina and just mate like
crazy kassadin has been studying
massaspora for about five years says
just before the cicadas rise on the
ground the spores of the fungus are to
infect the bug once it's above ground it
starts to shed its skin become an adult
his butt falls off
then a white plug of fungus grows in its
place oh nasty that's no fun it looks
like the backside of cicada is being
replaced either by chalk or by like one
of the nubby middle school erasers
the insects have no idea what's
happening the fungus however is pulling
the strings and making skaters want to
mate with everyone males that are
infected will continue to mate with
females but they'll also pretend to be
female so they can spread the fungus to
males what it's turning it's a bug
this fungus is turning to freaking
cicadas i don't like them putting fungus
in the cicadas
dude how come this stuff doesn't happen
to people
i'm not that upset about it
i think it does but i don't i don't have
fomo about that it's more subtle with
people like our bacteria our gut biome
is kind of pulling the strings of our
behavior you know eat food then you get
cravings that's like mind control um but
you see it real blatant in some animals
like where the the fungus infects the
brain of the worm and then it like or
the bug and then the bug starts going
crazy like zombie bug you guys want to
hear something real gross yeah dude so
uh we've got cicadas all over the place
you know what i mean and i've been
telling the story about like i catch
them right
the easiest way the easiest way for me
has been to get cicadas for the chickens
no no i just walk to the parking lot and
pick them up you know why
because the parking lot is it's blacktop
we got it sealed and so in the middle of
the day when the sun hits it and the
ground is so hot you can't walk on it
the cicadas will land and then just burn
to death oh nice they'll just die and so
i walk up and they're just like freaking
out and i just pick them up and throw in
the chicken thing and the chickens eat a
warm meal but today i came out cause i
can't get them all some have melted to
the pavement
nature is mad well it's not is it nature
i mean we're the ones who put the black
ops but what i mean we come from nature
too you know like we have an agent
that's true maybe
maybe blacktop is inhumane
in general you know what's worse but i
don't know animals do horrible stuff to
other animals i remember when we had the
17-year cicadas back where i grew up
they would be um coming out of their
shells this is also super gross but it's
not related to blacktop so we don't have
to feel guilty about it as they come out
of their shells and they shed their skin
they're like temporarily paralyzed and
ants would just like eat them alive from
the inside while they were yeah we would
find them like hollowed out near ant's
nest with just like a hole in their face
dude that's pretty awful so like this
new york post story get ready for sex
craze zombie cicadas known as flying
salt takers of death
the crazy thing about it is their butts
like are they fall off and then the
fungus grows out of it could you imagine
like if human beings like got infected
and their butts fell i couldn't i don't
want to
hold on hold on hold on hold on you just
hear me out a bunch of dudes their butts
fall off and is replaced by weird spongy
fungal spores
and then they just become like zombie
crazed and start pretending to be women
like trying to spread the fungus maybe
that's what the cicadas are doing maybe
it has happened in the past and there
was a war and they had to kill fungus
butts like they had they're like hey
fungus butt bro
hold on hold on
so you know there's like the last of us
where it's like those mushrooms take
over them no i haven't seen it they got
to do this they got to make it
fungus butt oh my god yeah the zombies
are like people like ah i want to do it
and they're like their butts are fungus
spores
no fun
no
so on the unemployment benefits
don't eat cicadas yeah dude how many
people do you think ate one of these
infected cicadas oh man oh man i don't
know is this oh no no i will not people
are eating bats they're eating cicadas
how many pandemics are we gonna have to
have people eating strange things dude
what if like it does spread to humans
because somebody saw the news about
eating cicadas like that would actually
be a crazy uh like video game premise
it's like post-apocalyptic and people
are all like fungus but zombies and it's
like in the year 2021 the media told
everyone to eat cicadas out of the
ground but they were infected and the
fungus spread to humans
how many people do you think actually
ate cicadas oh there's a restaurant
nearby that does it what yeah
tacos good really yeah where do they
farm them they the guy walks outside his
backyard and pulls them off to pull them
off the buildings could you imagine that
could you imagine like i'd like to go
get food and the guy's like oh just a
minute he lifts us up lifts a stone off
the ground and pulls grubs and garbage
out of the ground and just chucks it in
a pan dude he's like just coming right
up i'd be like nah i'm good dude
if i wanted to eat the bugs off the
ground i just do it myself bro this is
what the lion king was trying to program
us towards
the entire reason disney released that
propaganda film trying to make us like
timon and pumbaa yeah because they were
telling somebody eat the bugs yeah
because they because you know
simba was supposed to eat them yeah
exactly they're like like hold on have
you thought about bugs
and they're like oh it's so good and
he's like okay he eats bugs
no they were sincere though they
actually ate bugs before that they were
bug eaters you could tell they enjoyed
it too much when they introduced simba
to the concept of eating bugs but but
yes that hog in a meerkat they eat bugs
okay yeah exactly but i'm saying they
weren't being insincere they were like
yeah like you really should eat this so
we enjoy it they weren't being yeah you
know they actually enjoyed it this
wasn't like a long con i have uh are you
ready for the the post-apocalyptic
dollar collapse market crash zombie butt
eat the bugs future i don't know that
like ready is ever a word i could use to
describe my state with respect to that
but
i'm preparing
how are you preparing uh you know i've
got some i've got some emergency food
i've got some uh
got some weapons i've got some fungal
spray oh i'm not sure what else fungal
spray i'm coming to your house yeah
exactly now okay so uh
let me let's talk sheamus um yes you
know so we've got a wonderful compound
here yeah everybody has their very
important task what would you
uh what labor
what specialty could you fill here uh i
know what you're asking impressions a
impressions impressions b i could get
people to think and question authority
and question the command hierarchy that
you set up which is good which is in
that benefit i think which is great this
is why you want me around that that
would be like a funny skit like it's a
post-apocalyptic you know commune like a
literal commune after the apocalypse and
antifa shows up and they're like this is
horrible we'd like to no no they're like
we'd like
uh excellent um well uh what could you
contribute to the community
we can smash your buildings and make
everyone question the the social order
of your the delegate
the delicate fabric of your society uh
in a post-apocalyptic scenario um
intriguing intriguing and what will the
benefit of this be no benefit will just
destroy your way of life and racism
that's communist racism it will will end
the racism of you yeah and your and your
and your commune yeah i think it'd be
funny because like they would contribute
literally nothing literally nothing we
saw that with chop
remember that garden top chop i'm sorry
chas chop i don't know no goes on i
don't know what the preferred term is
but yeah no go zone yeah the no go zone
where they have the the little garden
thing that they set up yeah on top of
cardboard
they uh thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you